معنا من الخليل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس
قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل اهلا
بك معنا اذا الخلاف بين جالنت ونتنياهو
يتطور يتفاقم مع مرور الايام ومن تجلياته
رفض الظهور في مؤتمرات صحفيه وصل الامر
الان الى الاقتراب من الاشتباك بالايدي
كما نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ماذا يعني
ان يصل الخلاف الى هذه النقطه بين رئيس
حكومه ووزير الدفاع في زمن الحرب وليست اي
حرب
صباح الخير يعني انهم يعني ان الرجلان
وصلا الى نقطه اللا عوده في العلاقات فيما
بينهما بمعنى ان يعني السياق الحديث او
النقاش حول الخلافات الاسرائيليه الداخليه
كان في بدايه هذه الحرب وربما يعني حتى
منتصف هذه الحرب يدور حول كيفيه التعامل
مع قطاع غزه بمعنى الاشكاليه كانت تكمن في
ترتيب بعض اولويات مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
في كيفيه اداره الملفات الداخليه
الاسرائيليه لكن انتقلنا الى مستوى مختلف
تماما من الخلافات وصل حد القطيعه بمعنى
انه لم يعد هناك تواصل فعال ما بين جالانت
وبن مين نتنياهو ونحن لا نتحدث عن شخصيه
وزاريه هامشيه نحن نتحدث عن وزاره الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبرايي ان هذه الامور لم تاتي
بشكل مفاجئ يعني هذه مسائل يعني متراكمه
بدات بشكل يعني واضح جدا حين منع جالانت
من الالتقاء برؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه هذا
هو التط الاهم والاخطر والذي يعكس تخوف
بنيامين نتنياهو يعني غالبا النقاشات
عزيزتي كانت تكون في امكانيه انسحاب بيني
جانس وايزن كوت من مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
وكان دائما يشار الى هذا الموضوع على انه
ربما يؤدي الى تفكك مجلس الحرب وبالتالي
التراجع في العمليه العسكريه لكن بنيمين
نتنياهو كان تخوفه من مساله مختلفه تماما
مساله مرتبطه بامكانيه ان يكون الانسحاب
والانشقاق من اطراف في حزب الليكو لانه
انهيار مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي لا يعني
انهيار الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذا الامر كان
يدفع من يمين نتنياهو الى الاطمئنان شيئا
ما الى ان موقف بين جانس وايزن كوت لن
يؤثر على جوهر استقرار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لكن موقف جالنت على وجه
الخصوص هو الذي كان يدفع الى التخوف وهذا
ما يشير وهذا ما تشير اليه عمليات منع
جالنت من الحصول على معلومات يعني ان كنتم
تذكرون قبل ايام مثلا جالنت منع من
التواصل مع اي جهه لها علاقه بصفقه
الادويه يعني ان بنيمين نتنياهو يتخوف من
مسالتين اما ان جلند سيستثمر المعلومات
التي سيحصل عليها من الشاباك والموساد او
اي طرف له علاقه بصفقات التبادل بشكل شخصي
او سيستفيد منها لادانه بن يمين نتنياهو
اكثر لذلك بن يمين نتنياهو الان يحاول ان
يعني يضمن استقرار الائتلاف الحاكم اكثر
من استقرار مجلس الحرب وهذا الامر يع الى
الى التعام بهذه الطريقه على صعيد اخر ما
معنى ان يخرج مكتب نتنياهو ليكذب ان صح
القول ما خرج به بايدن عن ان نتنياهو لا
يعارض حل الدولتين وكان نتنياهو يبعث ايضا
برساله لجهه ما لطمها في الداخل
الاسرائيلي على انه ثابت على موقف فيما
يتعلق بمساله الدوله
الفلسطينيه انت محقه في ذلك بمعنى بنم
نتنياهو حين تواصل مع بايدن بدون ادنى شك
هو غير معني بتاجي الخلافات مع اداره
بايدن هو يعني بان يحفظ على الاقل شعره
معاويه ما بين الطرفين لذلك ربما لم ينف
الرجل خلال الاتصال انه يعني معارض انه
مؤيد ل لحل الدولتين لكنه لم يقر بذلك
فعلا بنص صريح لا في الاتصال ولا في غير
الاتصال ولا يمكنه ان يقول ذلك حين اقدم
بايدن على الافصاح عن هذا الموضوع نتاجا
لاحتياجات بايدن واداره بايدن والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لان يكون هناك افق
سياسي للعمليه العسكريه لتبرير هذا الدعم
الامريكي اللامتناهي لاسرائيل لابد ان
يكون هناك غطاء سياسي لذلك بايدن استثمر
هذه الفكره وحاول ان يطرحها لكن بنيامين
نتنياهو لديه معضله انه لا يستطيع ارضاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وارضاء جميع
الاطراف في اسرائيل وهنا يبدو ان بنمي
نتنياهو كان يفاضل والمفاضله كانت لصالح
قوى اليمين المتطرف لانه في نهايه المطاف
يمكنه ان يضحي بباي ددن لكن لا يمكنه ان
يضحي باي شكل من الاشكال ببنك فير وسموت
والقاعده اليمينيه الصلب التي يعتمد عليها
في استقرار حكمه لانه لم يتبقى لبنين
نتنياهو الان اي مبرر او مسوغ للتواجد على
راس الحكومه الاسرائيليه سوى ضمان استمر
استقرار ال 64 مقعد في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
ما دون ذلك لا يوجد اي تعويل لانه الذهاب
الى انتخابات مبكره يعني الخروج من المشهد
السياسي وفقا لاستطلاعات الراي التي يشار
اليها الان بالاضافه الى ذلك علاقته
بالقوى الاخرى علاقه مرتبكه